[Music]
this is currently the lowest price wagon
in the German market
the Duchy Logan MCV extinct and sixes
sonship the original Logan MCV was
extremely spacious and very cheap the
box a Romanian soon won fans among
thrifty families and tradesmen the new
version takes a step back from his van
associated past now the Logan MCV is
being marketed as a regular station
wagon and the differences are
immediately apparent it has a much
sleeker look with the headlights now
flush with the matte black grille
[Music]
and it has a lower roofline than its
predecessor with a more conventional
side profile the rear is where the
Logan's new image as a family car is in
its best light instead of these split
rear doors it has a classic trunk hatch
which proudly bears the name of the
model we think the old version was
quirkier and more individual
[Music]
in the hood it's a full 13 centimeters
shorter than the old version bringing it
down to 151 centimeters average for its
class instead of commercial customers
it's now more geared to normal families
and they are quite keen on the new Logan
MCV judging by advance orders da Chia
can hardly keep up with demand around 60
Logan MC V's come off the assembly line
every hour at the planet-protecting
Romania that adds up to 350,000 per year
a worrying number for other
manufacturers in Europe that's because
the top of the line Logan MC V can be
had in Germany for under 14 thousand
euros Sascha says the key fuel
consumption as low as possible Dacia has
helped itself to Reno's modern engines
there's the 0.9 liter 3-cylinder unit
also used in the renault clio
it delivers 66 kilowatts or 90
horsepower and only consumes 5 litres of
fuel per 100 kilometers
gachi offers two gasoline engines for
the Dutch Illogan MCV along with a
diesel and a natural gas option going
flat-out the three cylinder gasoline
version can reach a maximum of 175
kilometers per hour accelerating from
zero to 100 requires patience 11.1
seconds although no one should be
expecting high performance from a 66
kilowatt engine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
by the concepts the change to the
concept of the 4.49 metre long car has
unfortunately also taken its toll on the
trunk the old model had an unrivaled 700
mm 350 litres of luggage capacity but
now we have just a very ordinary 573 -
1518 litres late months if you fold down
the front passenger seat you get a
loading length of 2.74 meters
although the available space can't match
that of its predecessor the trunk is
extremely flexible folding down the rear
seats produces a more or less flat
surface give us help unfortunately says
Sascha
there is no optional third seat row in
the new generation in its place a spare
tire a jack and a set of tools
[Music]
that's fo [ __ ] Sasha says with a new
Logan MC Vita is following its usual
strategy that is the basic version is
extremely cheap at 7990 euros but is
virtually naked especially in terms of
the interior you have to pay more to get
a navigation system and air conditioning
compared to its predecessor the interior
is much more appealing
a comparison of the old and the new
three-part dashboard makes this clear
the armrest is well-intentioned but
still lacks a solid feel
[Music]
because even that said all trim levels
include power steering for airbags and
ESP time for our verdict Pais conceived
the Logan MCV has little competition on
the price front you'd usually pay 20,000
euros for a wagon of comparable size
even a mini wagon would still cost you
around 10,000 and you'd have to make
compromises in terms of space da Chia
wants to direct customers needing more
room to the new logic and docker but if
the space in the Logan MCV is sufficient
it offers a very good price performance
ratio means equal displays license
fitness